foreign
[Music]
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show where it is my job to
interview friends foes everyone in
between but the Common Thread is world
class performance and the attempt is
always to
dig to excavate to deconstruct the
lessons thought Frameworks and so on
that you can apply or test or simply
Ponder in your own lives my guest today
is a friend Jake Muse Jake music CEO at
Maui Nui venison a company he co-founded
in 2017 that works to balance invasive
access to your populations on the island
of Maui channeling that management into
incredible nutrient dense food now we
knew it was selected for fast Company's
top 10 most Innovative companies in
agriculture of 2023
and its venison has been served in top
restaurants across the country including
alinea which featured very heavily in
the four-hour Chef it was a big section
entirely because it's so impressive The
French Laundry and Saison where I just
mentioned
I was one of the very first investors
when it was a pop-up with 12 seats
something like that Josh skins everybody
should check him out as well prior to
Maui Nui Jake was executive director of
the axis deer Institute for 12 years
part of a two decades-long project
focused on access deer in their
long-term Management in Hawaii you can
find them at Maui Nui I'll spell that
out for folks
m-a-u-i-n-u-i venison.com and you can
find them on Instagram Twitter Etc at
Maui Nui venison I'm shocked those
handles were available
and I think we will start where all good
stories start and that's with lava oh
wow fast-moving lava so I'm going to use
that as the Q and I'm going to let you
run with it but let's begin with that
well thank you so much for having me
absolutely man it's great to see you
we're gonna have a blast lava
so in 2018
a fissure started erupting on the East
Rift Zone on the big island and it was
an area that had was a lava Zone
previously and and but had since been
built over so lots of homes there was
this beautiful area called kapoho which
had amazing like hot pools and tide
pools while it's now gone unfortunately
so anyway Fisher 8 starts erupting
it splits into two and it basically cuts
off a several thousand acre Area Homes
people and this lava flow is moving very
quickly 20 miles an hour so within a 24
hour period is about
three miles up the coast like it's
moving slower at the front but like
essentially cuts off this entire area
State and feds arrive right away they
start helicoptering people and different
people out people plants pets whatever
the people are holding deer
and then a cattle rancher had been cut
off and there was still 50 plus animals
left between these two flows and you can
imagine like it looked like Mordor on
the ground like they're like sulfur was
terrible there was lava bonds the
fissure was constantly
spewing at about 100 to 200 feet oh my
God yeah so like I think I think they're
not simmer no it was 20 I think they
said it was 26
000 cubic
meters of like lava
per like minute it was it was absurd it
was like one of the fastest moving flows
they'd ever seen so anyway
a Rancher did his best job to get the
majority of his cows out but there are
50 plus animals trapped between these
two lava flows and that's when you saw
the bat signal on the sky it well kind
of
and we had happened about a year ago to
develop the first of its kind live
capture net system that with a
helicopter you can essentially pick up
Kyle's live and get them out of there so
if you can imagine a cone-shaped net
with a 20 foot diameter frame on the
bottom and it's hanging from a hundred
foot line below a helicopter and so
helicopter's moving and this this net is
kind of flowing back and forth then you
place the net over the cowl
and then there's a switch at the top of
the cone and there's two lines and then
as the animal tries to move outside you
let the first switch goes at the top of
the cone and the net basically falls on
top of it and you just pick up the frame
and it's essentially sitting in a big
bag evenly distributed and then you fly
it out and you put this bag down and you
put the frame over and it just stands up
and walks away
got it so the frame
is
basically a rectangle or a square it's
an octagon yeah yeah octagon yeah okay
got it yeah so Federal Peta everybody
gets a hold of us and says like we need
to get these cows out of here and we
were just because it was it was known at
least to some subset of folks that you
had this you developed this yeah live
capture system we were previously using
it to try and get cows out of high
elevation critical Watershed areas where
they were causing like extensive damage
so they get a hold of us they run us
through like what they want us to do of
course I had to like sit down on the
team and say like do you want to try and
rescue cows over a 20 mile per hour lava
flow and I think one of the guys turned
over and he's like we would get to be a
lava cowboy and I was like oh man yeah
like come in who's who's gonna say no to
that one yeah and ended up like doing
our due diligence it was it was pretty
safe to do long story short we got them
all out but the first couple of days
were so intense and the very first cow
so
we're driving out there in the morning
it literally looks like Mordor like the
flow is creating its own weather system
it's raining it's dark like it's a two
mile flow so it's like lighting up the
entire area in like dark red and you're
driving towards it and you're thinking
like oh and you're passing like all
these National Guards you're just like
this doesn't seem like a great idea on
your way out yeah and we get all loaded
up in the morning the head of peta's
there like it's this huge thing there
had been so much
loss already they had lost that entire
Community hundreds of homes gone and
there had been so much loss and it's the
community was kind of starting to gather
around this idea of these things that
were left behind we could actually get
them
and get there in the morning we get all
set up
get dialed in with the pilot he had
actually never done it before but it was
the only helicopter big enough that we
could pick up those particular cows
names Kelvin Dorn he's just an absolute
Legend
so we fly out first thing in the morning
like heading towards Fisher eight it's
fountaining 200 feet in the air like
there's lava bombs like that look like
they're going at the height of the
helicopter the cows are trapped like
right underneath it there's video there
so we can yeah put it in the show notes
oh man it's crazy and he goes to pick up
the first cow
grabs the first cow does it all right
and then he goes to lift and he's like
oh this might be too heavy
I don't know and this is like I have my
sulfur dioxide like I have my monitors
on like we're not supposed to get on the
ground and the net is attached to the
helicopter and he's like what do we do
and I was like well give it another tug
see if he can get off the ground so he
gives another tug and he like gets a
little bit off the ground and I'm like
okay
can we head downhill and you can get
some elevation he's like here's what
we're gonna do we're going to use the
heat from the lava flow to give us a
boost
Ride The Thermals we're gonna ride The
Thermals up with this cowl underneath us
and it should give us a big enough boost
we'll have enough elevation and then
like we'll be able to get down to the
Corral system it's crazy enough that it
just might work yeah and I'm thinking I
mean you don't really you don't really
have a choice you're like sure let's try
that
so he gets this cow off the ground and
he's moving at like a good speed and
we're picking up a little Innovation and
I can see like the lava flow coming at
like 500 yards 400 yards 300 yards and
we hit the flow and it's like somebody
kicked us in the nuts we just went
straight up in the air there was so much
heat coming off the flow and I looked
down to see what was happening to the
cow because
the cow is 100 feet lower than us yeah
and this cow swings out and then as it
passes over the top of the flow all we
see is just like smoke oh no
and I thought like the head of Peter is
sitting down watching the cow get
vaporized like I'm going to jail
something terrible is going to happen to
us this thing is over and we gain
elevation and we start to come out over
the flow and I'm looking down I'm like
oh God and I had forgotten that
it was pouring rain ah right and it was
soaked and all of that water like it
just instantly vaporized and it looked
like the whole thing was essentially
like on fire for a second so we come out
and like I see all the water vapor clear
and I'm like oh thank God and come down
land that animal gets out walks away
happy as can be and then I think we got
like seven or eight more of that day
before they kind of shut us down and got
a little crazy and and we ended up
getting all 50 animals out of that place
wow and happened to be one of the most
intense moments of my life
certainly maybe not the most dangerous
but I thought we were I thought we were
in a lot of trouble for that one but it
was just such a
like viscerally intense scenario yeah
you have like these lava bombs going off
and these two flows and what a really
cool experience in that Community like
there was this celebration when
everything for months had been just a
lot of loss so so let's set the stage a
bit by talking about the history of
Hawaii okay and maybe we could start for
a second just with the name Maui Nui
what does Maui NUI mean because even
people who live in the lower 48 or
continental US many people have not been
to Hawaii yeah and certainly people
overseas many of them will not have been
to Hawaii but what does Maui Nui refer
to so mauinui refers to the three
islands of Maui Molokai and
epochs ago they used to be joined they
used to be one giant Island like the
Pangea of Hawaii yeah and you can see it
when you look at like couple Maps or
Google Earth like you can see they used
to be joined when we
we're deciding on a name we didn't know
where management might take us but
access deer are located on those three
islands so we landed at Maui Nui as as
kind of the name yeah wow and Nui is is
it fair to say a suffix that is used or
maybe it's just the order of kind of
noun adjective but big yes sir good job
like thanks a lot yep right this may be
a way to get into the history also okay
because we were chatting a little bit
about it I've been spending more time in
New Zealand and I'm fascinated by by
Maori culture oh and there is a very
close relationship yeah between what
we're talking about yeah and the culture
in New Zealand could you speak to that a
bit sure and then after that and you can
tie this in however you like but speak
to sort of the agriculture of
pre-colonized Hawaii
so I'm going to speak to this as best I
can right you're gonna have to have and
okay actually let's hit pause for a
quick second because I think it's worth
mentioning up front so a company you
co-founded in 2017 who is your
co-founder my extraordinary wife she's
amazing yeah can you say a little bit
about for a second sure I mean first and
foremost the mother of three amazing
children a brilliant
person all around funny smart beautiful
but she is a genealogist and a bit of a
historian and she helps
maybe she guides a lot of culture within
what we do but she has a such an
in-depth understanding of our place
she'd be somebody amazing to have on if
you ever wanted to really dig in but
she's just this anchor for me personally
and professionally to how we should be
operating in this place
how long has her family been in Hawaii
well she'll tell you forever yeah
exactly yeah and she also if I'm
remembering correctly looks at old
microfiche newspapers yeah and sort of
excavates and translates so
post-western contact
when they they didn't have a written
language prior to but post-western
contact they became the most literate
Society in a matter of like 50 years I
think 93 to 94 of the entire population
could read and write and in doing so
they created hundreds and hundreds of
newspapers that like she shows me
newspapers where like there's a picture
of like a drawn picture of a zebra like
oh this thing is from Africa like it was
extraordinary the level of information
that they had and I think they were also
in understanding their place
post-western contact and how quickly
their populations were declining they
were using it as this historical record
and so they were just writing everything
down and so what she helps to do is only
two percent of those newspapers have
been translated
98 of what could be like their culture
is sitting in these newspapers ready to
be discovered and it's just like a
treasure hunt for her every time she
looks like like she comes out and it's
just like her eyes are giant she's like
I found a new name for this rain and
she's just like she she's gonna write an
amazing book one day and also I mean
she's very
much multi-hyphenate polymath because
she's also an incredible designer yeah
really incredibly good and gifted and I
hesitate to say gifted she is gifted but
that maybe
sounds like it minimizes the hard work
and dedication required to get good at
it and an incredible writer also on top
of that so I wanted to mention that
because
that underscores the connection that she
has and that you as a family feel with
the land so I wanted to just mention
that up front
and then we can go back to the
pre-colonial Agriculture and the tie
between New Zealand yeah so I mean I
think you could Define this culture as
literal Geniuses they were able to
navigate all of the Pacific Ocean with
extraordinary like accuracy and directly
speaking about El taroa
so
El taroa was settled from Hawaii and for
people who who don't know the matching
so aotearoa is the Maori word for what
is also known
they kept such amazing records of their
voyages my brother-in-law got to spend a
whole bunch of time there with Maori in
different communities they have the
actual boats the canoes that were
settled from Hawaii they know like the
lineage of like who came on the boat and
they know where the boats are they have
them hidden and they know where the
boats are and that's how strongly they
can connect their ties back to Hawaii
and you just have to imagine that
somebody that could navigate the Pacific
with
that much
ease and accuracy and like it's
extraordinary to hear these stories
they also were dealing with like they're
on the most isolated landmass on the
planet with the most finite resources
and so they develop as far as I know
some of the most ingenious agricultural
systems I've ever heard of
a great example they're called the
Kohala field systems they had
500 miles of what looked like from the
air
swelled permaculture lines
and they used
273 different varieties of sweet potato
to produce oh I just remember they are
producing now yields 60 better than
current sweet potato yields then you
have to imagine pre-western contact
there were up to a million people in the
Hawaiian Islands wow and there's only
1.4 million people now so they had a
million people on the most isolated
landmass on the planet and they were
feeding
extraordinary population with extremely
finite resources and somehow were able
to maintain all of the biodiversity
I think they only know of like a couple
small species like a flightless bird
that was just too easy to eat
they maintained extraordinary
biodiversity which just really points to
how connected to that place were they
had these amazing
they call them lokoia but they were fish
ponds so I don't know if you remember
when you when you were there but there's
these huge rock walls that come out into
the ocean near shore yeah some of them
like 600 acres and they had these
amazing aquaculture systems where they
were able to harvest fish constantly and
they said at Peak Performance there were
500 plus fish ponds across the Hawaiian
Islands producing three million pounds
of fish
and that's like apart from what they
were also catching outside of
those ponds as well like Innovation is
culture in that place and she continues
to like help Point me back to like I
don't know we're gonna figure this out
we're a part of this place like we're
gonna figure out how to find balance in
these places they just had some amazing
both agricultural system but also like
economics and social systems they had a
particular system called an ahua system
and it was
Mountain to Ocean land segregations that
entire communities lived in and managed
and they were managed as like these
individual land segments and the entire
system was built from top to bottom to
protect water
every feature of that system how the
food was grown how like it entered the
water everything was built to maintain
good clean water
so let's segue from that
to
ask steer
what on Earth are axis deer
number one
what is the history of their presence in
Hawaii why did they end up there
and
then I have follow-up questions
that relate to water
so in
1868 the then Kamehameha the fifth was
given
this gift who is the leader at the time
the then ruler of the Hawaiian Islands
came from India
down the upper Ganges to Hong Kong like
she helped translate the story
my wife did cool
and then they were moved from Oahu where
they landed and they were moved to the
small island of Molokai you know only 40
miles long 10 miles wide and then a kapu
which is a restriction was placed on
them for about 15 to 20 years what does
that mean a couple is like nobody was
allowed to hunt them or touch them and
how many deer seven seven yeah
and as early as
1898 there's literature that says they
hired Sharpshooters from California well
that was 1902. they brought sharp
producers in from California because
there was already six to seven thousand
of them and what's really unique about
access deer is they're one of the only
deer species in the world that can breed
year-round so most other deer species
will cast their antlers their antlers
fall off right of the year and when that
happens their testosterone levels drop
significantly and their sperm is no
longer viable so actually you're one of
the only deer species in the world that
sperm stays viable year round so it
doesn't matter if a dough is missed in
estrous they are like
the current math that we have is they
are like 94 to 95 of them are either
lactating or pregnant year-round wow so
they just introduced an extraordinarily
viral species
and have had profound impacts with that
type of growth rate so if we then flash
forward to
roughly 10 years ago or 12 years ago
what did the situation look like
anyway with respect to axis deer which
have no natural Predators yeah so on
that land mass yeah in India they
certainly did yeah so no natural
Predators the capability to breed
year-round extraordinary
like food sources and being able to move
up and down elevation to find what they
need so on the island of Molokai where
they were introduced
they're now at a
sustainable capacity is the wrong word
but then their population is only going
up and down with available feed every
year and what's happening is they just
have massive die-offs what do the
numbers look like 70 000 and there's
only 7 000 people wow yeah is actually
one of the reasons I got
so interested in the subject as a whole
is I think it was my second
year in college and then introduced this
amazing family and I was there
hunting trying to fill up my freezer for
college because I was broke and like
and I was there during a die-off and I
remember coming around this corner and
seeing
40 to 50 animals just lying there
lethargic essentially dying of
malnutrition and it was an animal that
was introduced to me as like something
to love and it was precious like for the
people of Molokai it was this amazing
food source but it's just this that's
the only way they're currently balancing
populations is just this like really sad
thing that happens every overpopulation
famine yeah and then it corrects yeah
and then it corrects they lose about
like a third of the population every
seven to ten years
and what is the impact
on the various Islands
ecologically because I I remember
watching first time
this video that you guys produced in
collaboration with a number of other
folks and hearing voice over I think it
was with people talking about flying
over certain areas and saying oh wow we
didn't know the Wildfire reached this
far and the answer was that's not
Wildfire yeah
they are able to because they can eat so
closely to the ground and they're so
like in such large numbers there can be
herds of like four to five thousand
they're able to Denude landscapes in
days
and
the real issue with that is when they do
that in our Watershed areas our high
elevation areas
those trees developed over
like epochs thousands and thousands of
years to capture water
and what ends up happening is when we
have like some data from this from a
recent
study those watersheds are operating at
50 of their previous capacity
so in I guess there are multiple issues
at the consequences of that right one is
you're just not capturing water which is
important if you're in the middle of the
ocean unless you have a massive
desalination program yeah you need the
rain water what is the effect that has
on runoff
so when you think about it from like a
mo they call it mauka to Makai but like
Mountain to Ocean impact what the all of
that denuded landscape
anytime we get any type of like
significant rain even like a decent like
a medium rain these days it's pulling
all of that topsoil which took
thousands of years to make and then it's
depositing it on our briefs and what
ends up happening is they're smothering
both new and old coral and the coral dye
so there's huge tracks of what used to
be some of the most pristine reefs in
the world that are now dead and that
also then impacts near shore Fisheries
so we just had this amazing conversation
about producing millions of pounds of
fish free western contact and now a lot
of those Roof Systems being like very
negatively impacted by that sediment
deposit from runoff and then when you
look back up slope
mid-range call it like
a thousand to six thousand feet is where
our food systems in Hawaii are so it's
where cattle ranchers operate and
farmers and coffee and all of these
different
really important as a function of food
security like all these amazing foods
that we're trying to grow there and you
can't grow them unless you have a 10
foot fence at forty five dollars a foot
forty five dollars a foot yeah that's
not cheap no so
they are also having a severe impact on
our food system so ecosystems Food
Systems near shore
fisheries and reefs there's it is a
compounding conversation so to then take
a look at how seriously people in Hawaii
are taking this
let's talk about
the three-year hunt
and we'll build from there okay
and actually I'll just add one sidebar
I'll put this in the show notes as well
for people who are interested in
learning more about the incredible
navigational skills that you're
referring to there's a really
beautifully written detailed chapter in
a book called The wayfinders by Wade
Davis that talks about the sort of
Polynesian diaspora and their ability to
navigate and it is mind-blowing it's a
real mistake to think of some of these
ancient Technologies as primitive
they're not always primitive they're
just different sets of skills and
Technologies but they would have the
captain as one person the head of the
ship just making everything
orchestrate and the Navigator would be a
separate person and they would basically
sit like a Zen Monk and not sleep at all
because they're tracking multiple
currents they're keeping track of where
the boat is in space even when it's
totally overcast and they can't use yeah
the Stars I mean it's unbelievable so I
recommend people check out the
wayfinders by Wade Davis
through your hunt got it
the access to your Institute which was
what I started
in college
initially as a means to collect
information because nobody in India
would answer me
and then became like very much a
way to learn more and facilitate some
research
four axis deer were illegally introduced
to the big island of Hawaii so we've
talked about and Maui so for Access deer
were illegally introduced to the big
island of it which is about 10 years ago
and the big island is it's called the
Big Island for a reason all of the
Hawaiian Islands can fit inside the big
island and it is also like the food Hub
of Hawaii we grow all of our vast
majority of food on the big island
and the impacts of access here were
already really well known so it was a
state emergency when these animals were
found and the access to the Institute
happened to be one of the few people
that knew a lot about access deer so we
were given that responsibility and
contract to try and find and remove
four deer from a hundred square mile
area
so they didn't know where they were yeah
and these aren't elephants oh no what's
this what's the size profile just so
people can conjure an image
150 pounds think about them standing you
know
three and a half four feet high maybe
six feet long yeah so a pretty small
yeah what are the biggest differences
for people who might be more familiar
with say a whitetail well the biggest
difference is where they evolved
accessory evolved with Bengal tigers and
leopards in dense jungle and so they are
they have this crazy Sixth Sense yeah
their agility is unbelievable yeah and
they're just vigilance and
sensory perception is
incredible yeah to observe I think
because they didn't deal with some of
the evolutionary stresses of like
seasons in India they've also developed
this amazing ability to adapt their home
ranges to very safe areas typical home
range could be like a mile and a half to
three miles in a given day but when they
find a safe spot like they will stay in
a very small area for an extended period
of time I see so they move less than say
a whitetail and therefore they're better
able to Denude yes a concentrated area
so they'll find these little cubby holes
these safe areas and they'll kind of
completely denoo these areas and then
move on to these next places but for the
project on the big island which was
literally a three-year hunt like we work
every single day except Sunday for three
years to find these four animals did
they multiply in the meantime or no yeah
we ended up removing five
[Music]
but
it was this extraordinary exercise it
took us seven months
like you think you're going on like an
average hunt like it's three or four
days and you're already tired it took us
seven months to get a camera trap image
of the first one we
we had 50 plus camera traps all over
every piece of water we could find in
this like 100 square mile area piece of
water you mean ponds or lakes ponds Blue
Rock that water would pull in anything
we could find water troughs any water
sources so we finally get a camera trap
image so we're like okay we have an idea
of look at this endless it takes us
another four months to get the first one
what do you do between so you set up the
cameras you're like we know these
animals need water yeah and set up the
traps
and take seven months so you get an
image yeah
oh my God if we got our first image and
then it takes another how long three
months okay what are you doing in those
three months so
two things are happening one we're doing
transects looking for sign so you would
love this like you're tracking every
single day you're just looking for the
tiniest sign that they're in an area
trying to you used an expression
transect something or other transects so
you're basically breaking into grids you
know what you've covered at I think
we're doing 10 meters like massive areas
but what we also did in the process
which we'll move into like our later
story is we had to find a way to
increase detection rates and so we
started and it was such a huge emergency
that the military was involved as well
so we got to work with the military and
utilize some of their forward-looking
infrared both helicopter mounted and
binoculars and the minute we started
using that tool
we knew instantly like this is the tool
that's going to be able to like find
these animals so forward-looking if red
Fleur flirt yeah Fleur is can we think
of this as sort of black and white
Predator Vision yes from the
Schwarzenegger movie okay exactly you
put the mud on you like it's detecting
heat and turning it into a visual image
for you to use
and if you're cool and or like not
emitting he can't find you I posted a
video you sent me of Fleur footage from
a drone which if you want to see this
scope the magnitude
of the problem in terms of just the
volume of animals with respect to access
Theory you have to see this video it'll
blow your mind I put it on Instagram
we'll link to that in the show notes as
well yeah and we ran out of range yeah
yeah exactly yeah it's not like they
stopped yeah but it looks like a
veritable New York City of axis here
yeah at night yeah unbelievable so this
particular technology which Inc like
significantly increases detection rates
both from the ground but from a
helicopter platform as well especially
when looking straight down you don't
have the vertical layering of vegetation
you're able to kind of look straight
down through vegetation and pick up
different
heat signatures that's actually how we
ended up finding them after the camera
trap image is we started flying on a
constant basis and then we figured out
where they were took a week to kind of
put a plan together and then we were
able to remove when was this
11 years ago 11 years ago yeah we're
using quadcopters or a different type of
drone
no we were flying out of a helicopter
very early days
yeah so we were out of a helicopter
leaning out of the helicopter like with
a binocular
yeah it was not a lot of fun and we were
doing it four or five hours a day yeah
that will make you motion sick or
anything yeah so yeah well I've got lots
of those stories
anyway takes us another two years
essentially but utilizing that
technology we were able to find and
remove all of those deer including the
the two that had been born and there
were very few invasive species projects
that are successful in Hawaii period
really cool fact
introduction of species to Hawaii
pre-human contact was every 25 to 50 000
years it was whatever came through like
wind or water right yeah there is a new
species being introduced every eight
days at this point in Hawaii yeah so and
again like the perfect place to
grow anything it's a side note and this
might be a total useless side alley that
I'm taking a step why are there so many
chickens in oh I love this story oh okay
here we go yeah they bring in Mongoose
okay
the powers that be decided we're going
to get rid of the Rat population by
bringing in Mongoose one of their
predators well they didn't realize that
Mongoose like are awake during the day
and rats are awake at night oops oops
like giant oops so I guess what mangas
are really good at killing other things
like including our native birds which is
just like the introduction of some of
these species are so absurd anyway so on
the big island Maui
a
they have Mongoose and there's no
chickens guess which island doesn't have
Mongoose Kawaii why don't they have
Mangus they came to the dock like they
were introducing them to each island
they came to the dock and somebody at
the dock was smart enough and they like
booted them off and drowned them
he like booted him off the dock and
drowned them yeah and it's just this
amazing contrast of you can't find a
chicken on another Island on the side of
the road and you can drive on Kauai and
see a thousand chickens in yeah 30
minutes yeah on the side of the road so
well I mean these
highly biodiverse isolated environments
are so beautiful and compelling and also
so fragile to disruption
true with New Zealand as well yeah I
mean in terms of biosecurity it is the
highest one of the highest priorities
right and they do an amazing job Hawaii
is doing better but they've done a very
poor job over the years in restricting
what's coming into the island
back to that three-year hunt so
successful in removing an invasive
species that there could have been a
million plus access deer on the big
island that's how large the big island
is and would have been absolutely
devastating as we talked about for like
Food Systems watersheds like near shore
Fisheries et cetera et cetera yeah and
then that was actually the jumping off
point for what is now Maui Nui is
some ranchers on on Maui said well wait
a second you guys actually did that and
you have this technology so what we also
developed with that third technology is
highly accurate surveys so through
within 95 we can tell you exactly the
number of deer that are there
how do you do that so transex again at
400 meters and then you take a sample no
so don't do a sample count because a lot
of people do that right and then they
multiply it out yeah so they do
something called distance sampling which
is they fly a certain number of
transects and then use math to basically
extend what they've found and make a
guess over a period
we do a complete transect of the entire
area at 400 meters with a 20 overlap so
we can have a confidence interval of
like the number of times you've detected
deer twice and we have done several
projects where it's in a large fenced
area of a couple thousand acres and we
survey we removed here we survey again
and we're never off by more than like
five percent that's wow so we have a
tool that can accurately tell us the
exact number of deer and the impact of
our management and it's a tool it's just
super important because otherwise I
think
what we do would be irresponsible
without that level of data yeah without
that yeah level of precision
the folks on my way said like if you can
do that come over here and they were
still calling them
spotted rats like that was their
relationship they had been introduced to
Maui in the in 1959 and 1960 so they
weren't
as culturally ingrained as they are on
Moloko and just to paint a picture for
folks so the spotted the axis deer
please
fact check the [__] out of this if I get
anything wrong but they're very
streamlined animals
they're not as beefy as Whitetail their
antlers are angled more backwards
and they have I'd say just generally
speaking a very Tawny
kind of burnt orange color with white
spots and that's hence the spotted rats
yeah and apple coloring was used in the
like those jungled environments and they
just they camouflage between their
grassland like it's amazing how well
they'll Japanese deer have the same
similar pattern yeah yeah
so it started the
well wait a second if you can be
successful with a project at that scale
what can you do over here on Maui and
that was actually the
first phone call to the USDA to say how
do we use these animals because they
were talking about having us remove
thousands and thousands of animals and
they didn't care what we did with them
they knew there wasn't a solution like
we couldn't use them for food and we
couldn't donate them like they still
need to come under on some type of like
food safety inspection program in order
to donate them to food banks and stuff
so that was the first call to the USDA
to say well wait a second what would be
the process because there were no rules
in place well it was just considered off
the table yeah right yeah so there are
rules that just never been applied yes
to this type of harvesting yeah so that
three-year hunt was the springboard into
successful project completion in that
place where there's where there's still
no deer and potentially had a massive
impact and then the springboard to Maui
to try and do something more so I'm
gonna do a little like
flashback awesome powers well or Wayne's
World maybe get my Mike Myers stuff
mixed up did you learn about confidence
intervals playing volleyball
I think actually no it was in the worst
class of my life whether it's business
statistics and College
but ended up being useful yeah you can't
imagine how much of that stuff actually
comes back yeah all right all right so
of course I'm teasing a bit by bringing
up the volleyball just briefly so people
have a little bit more color sure where
does volleyball fit into your life and
where does free pizza fit into your life
was a classic Canadian kid played a lot
of hockey until we were too broke to
play hockey anymore too broke to play
hockey just too much gear yeah too much
gear growing too fast uh right I forgot
about that right it would be like
replacing your ski equipment I remember
my dad sitting down and being like I
know you love it but you need to pick a
different sport yeah and they're like
volleyball requires knee pads that's all
you need like your knees shouldn't grow
as much here's a great sport for you to
try yeah ended up falling in love with
it just an extraordinary sport you know
redirecting balls moving 100 plus miles
an hour
luckily got pretty good at it spent a
lot of time with like our Canadian
national teams in different forms and
then was recruited to play at the
University of Hawaii
I was a decent enough player I actually
think it was I sent them a video of
Surfing we started surfing on the east
coast of Canada when we moved out there
and there's like six feet of snow and a
tiny little like ice floating around and
they're like well if this kid can do
this like he'll probably turn into a
good provider played four or five years
there where
became
a family member for that family of
moloka you were we talked about earlier
like was able to travel because the east
coast of Canada was so far really lucky
to play professional volleyball for
three years got to play in throughout
Europe the Maldives Indonesia so pause
can you frame for folks who don't have
the contacts a lot of people want how
big how popular is volleyball it's not
something that people in the US
generally watch at all yeah in Canada
there was nobody yeah it was my mom and
dad like cheering us on yeah but Hawaii
happened to be like it's the mecca of
volleyball like worldwide or just in the
US oh just in the U.S they have a they
actually won the last two national
championships over the last couple years
but they have a 20 000 seat stadium that
they filled on a regular basis for men's
volleyball and then you go overseas to
Europe do people watch volleyball in
Europe yeah it's huge so volleyball is
kind of the second sport to football or
soccer so you were associated with
another club yeah and you just got
basically spillover of all the soccer
fans or football fans but a huge
professional League there that for great
players pays extraordinarily well and
for for me which was not a great player
was this amazing opportunity to go to
Europe
see all of these different places and
the professional teams only ever
accepted two International Players so
you were in embedded and immediately
assimilated into whatever culture you
were in it's just such an amazing way to
be a part of those places versus some
Outsider right so that leads into the
story of like free pizza so my first
week playing in gronigan which was in
Northern Holland ski and Gesundheit yeah
well that plays into this story
I had like a week of practice and our
first game was
coming up and I was still very much like
getting used to the language the
cultures this like six eight Olympic
Legend he was like this legendary Dutch
player
and I think he was kind of happy I was
there but like I was I was just another
player and you're paid to be there so
you play really well he's trying to mine
with you to get things done right he's
not giving it a lot of effort
and then we're playing one of the best
teams of the league for the very first
game we're doing really well he
puts a play together to finish the game
I had no idea what he was saying
okay what could go wrong completely
screw it up like embarrassing level
screw up and we lose and after the game
he comes up comes aside in broken
English and he's just like you play
better or we fire you like you weren't
playing for fun anymore in college like
you were getting paid to play really
well and I didn't understand the reason
I didn't play walls because I didn't
couldn't understand what he was saying
yeah so the very next day we were
reviewing film and he was going off
again and I didn't understand what it
was and I just remember putting my like
putting my hand up and say like does
that mean we get free pizza after the
game and he's like what
and I was like does that mean we get
free pizza after the game he's like no
that's not what it means and then like
you could kind of see his brain be like
and he explained no we're going to be
committing on this individual like he
explained it in English to me yeah half
an hour goes by he's getting ready to
tell us the bus schedule it's all in
Dutch I have no idea what's going on and
I'm like put my hand up does that mean
we get free pizza and he he's just like
he's getting irritated and then I think
it finally collecting is like wait a
second we need to be a little bit more
patient with this guy yeah and I tell it
as a funny story because I used that
phrase as I went to Indonesia and the
Maldives and it was this amazing way for
me to ask dumb questions
because otherwise I was lost
and it has translated to one of these
small superpowers that I have where I am
never afraid now to ask the dumbest
question in front of some of the
smartest people
through kind of that practice and it
really is it's a superpower I want to
highlight this because it's really
important right and I have another
friend Mike Maples Jr and oftentimes
when he wants to ask a question that no
one else is going to ask but it's an
important question
but people are nervous to ask it for any
number of reasons and he'll go something
along these lines he's from Texas and
he'll be like you know I'm just a
country boy I move a little slow so bear
with me about let me ask you and he's
actually razor sharp right but he has
that as a way to sort of wrap a question
that needs to be asked yeah in the same
way that you were able to buy yourself
permission to ask these questions which
by the way a lot of the dumb questions
are on everyone else's mind not in this
particular case with everyone else who
speaks Dutch but there's so many
circumstances where
there's some type of pink elephant
question but people are nervous to ask
it because they don't look stupid or A B
C D or e but in fact it's a really
important question when I was playing
Indonesia we had a Brazilian guy that
spoke even last English than me and he
after my third day of asking for free
pizza he came up to me and he was like
thank you so much like I wouldn't know
what's going on unless you were like
asking these questions yeah and now it
just translates to like last week we're
building a API which I have no idea what
the hell this thing and like I just kept
saying I have no idea what you're
talking about and I kind of had a clue
but I could see like the blank looks on
the zoom calls nobody knew what they
were talking about and it just gets
stuff done so much faster yeah yeah and
it's just been this like amazing thing
in my life that has worked really really
well
just to put a bow on the the chapter of
volleyball so you mentioned that you
were not like the Ronaldo volleyball
yeah
but you ended up kind of taking an
oblique angle and
finding extending your career related to
volleyball how did you do that ended up
helping other players find contracts
yeah so I had a couple players that that
I knew that said like
you're not that good how did you get
like just being honest here you're like
you're not that good how did you get a
contract in Europe and I said well I
just called everybody so they kept
answering and was kind of working with
this other player agency anyway I found
a great way to find mediocre players
teams and some of them were only getting
a thousand Euros a month but they didn't
care yeah it was the best thing ever and
then got a small percentage of that
salary and yeah yeah it was an amazing
way to kind of extend that life and it
was a lot of fun okay so let's come back
to mauinui
and
they're a whole different
number of angles that I I want to take
to cover some of what I think are
interesting features of things
and a lot of them tie into
why Maui Nui became my first ever
I mean really if you look at my
portfolio food investment yeah in 2000
when was it 2019
so it was a while ago
part of it was I think there's a myopia
perhaps
with many people who specialize in some
form of early stage investment let's
just say Tech to associate Innovation
purely with technological advances in a
certain medium or in a certain capacity
but
I saw a lot that you guys were doing
that reflected a level of
experimentation and sort of unorthodox
thinking that was super attractive to me
that made me think it would be
in combination with other things like
nutrient density which we'll talk about
attractive
and also everything is [__] delicious
and I like delicious healthy things
let's talk about the seven on seven off
because this will sound at first
description to be a little odd for a lot
of folks sure so we have a very
unique schedule for our team members and
all of our team members work seven days
on seven days off
and they get a great compensation
package great benefits and it was
originally designed to deal with
flipping back and forth from the sleep
schedule all our harvesting operates at
night and we wanted to give our
Harvesters enough space to essentially
like recover and and feel good and be
able to come back to work and when we
started to grow we decided to keep that
system for essentially almost all of our
field and butcher staff like the vast
majority of who we are and it's turned
into this extraordinary
benefit that we didn't see kind of
coming and we did in a little experiment
last year because we wanted to make sure
we're living in Hawaii's extraordinarily
expensive and we wanted to we're trying
to be as responsible as possible so we
have two full teams
everybody that works 70s on and another
team comes in we essentially work
non-stop switching back and forth so we
offered them unlimited overtime can you
guess what happened
tell me nobody took it explain for a
second what that would actually mean
what is unlimited yeah so we said on
your seven days off you can come in and
work every single one of those days you
weren't at time and a half like at an
overtime rate and no one did it nobody
did what do you make of that
time they were just happy with hey
there's nothing more important than time
B lots of them it's been this really
interesting and amazing thing to watch
them
seven days is a long time yeah when we
hire somebody almost inevitably their
first week off they call me and they're
like what am I supposed to do like it's
day four and they're like I haven't had
a seven day vacation in three years what
am I supposed to do I'm like well get
used to it find some Hobbies yeah and
it's been amazing to watch them become a
better Community member or start a food
truck or start their own company and
they come back like we essentially have
100 retention of the people we want and
they come back on the start of their
seven days and they are the most
extraordinary person coming back to us
and then they work amazingly well for
seven days like that age-old adage of
one person is is better than two average
is a hundred percent true and we have
data to support that in how we look at
production and stuff now
the other thing that I think is really
important for the people we hire which
are hyper local people we're looking for
like people of those places is you're
giving them an opportunity to leverage
that place and enjoy it so half of them
will just fish for six days or like go
hunting or enjoy surfing or something
else and it's just this amazing schedule
that really allows them to enjoy the
place that they are from and live in but
more importantly we have an
extraordinary group of people and it
just had to roll over the hill a little
bit in that combine of other things like
through covid when nobody could hire
anybody we had Stacks and stacks and
stacks of resumes on my desk it's just
has turned into this amazing work
environment and we've had no lack of
essentially like efficiency or
production
so let's let's talk about some of the
processes and metrics that inform that
output and efficiency sure because it
doesn't happen by accident no and I've
visited your operation a few times now
and
I've always been this won't surprise
anyone who's followed me for a while I'm
always impressed with very finely tuned
tracking
so could you speak to some of the
metrics that you track
and why they're important sure and then
we'll segue from that into let's
have you describe what a shift actually
looks like sure when you're going out at
night
and you can feel free to switch back and
forth or do one and the other afterwards
so the Harvest side of what we do which
is really the unique aspect of
what we've built is these field
harvesting systems that comply fully
with USDA standards I.E everything that
operates in a brick and mortar we're
able to do in the field through a
combination of forward-looking infrared
and these different like software
systems that we built and we were only
able to create those systems and levels
of efficiency with what you're pointing
to is an absurd amount of data that we
keep so we keep track of every mile
every bullet every time we stop the moon
phases how the moon phase influences
deer we call it like moonfluence and we
have these giant kpis and sheets that
basically be performance indicators yes
that dictate where we go what we do and
then who we put in different places
actually I don't think I've told you
this but we just submitted a grant to
NASA these phds at Harvard and MIT found
out about what we did found out we keep
an absurd amount of data compared to
most agricultural companies and NASA has
a grant available before AG companies
where they'll fly this amazing satellite
comes over Hawaii at 1014 we just
finished putting this giant Grant
together
crossing my fingers and
it's so detailed that these amazing
people at MIT and Harvard believe
they'll be able to detect deer with the
satellite and then use the information
and data we collect every single night
on when we're seeing them and how and
how we're interacting with them to
incorporate with the machine learning to
create route planning for us so they
think a combination of satellite data
and the ground data that we keep
combined will be able to tell us on the
next day where to go wow I was freaking
out when they were explaining all of
this and lots of dumb questions that
went along with it yeah but they were
shocked at the amount of data we keep
they even got to see like we've run lots
of different experiments of how we
collect data and I think
maybe what your point can do is just
this constant iteration of we're going
to try this thing we're going to keep
data and if you don't measure
I think there's that great saying
measure what matters if you don't
measure it you won't know if it's
actually worked and we are just
constantly changing and measuring things
and so we've actually taken that
philosophy into our butcher facility
which is a very
well-known industry with well-known
inputs and like production efficiencies
and
we're crushing those numbers and we're
just doing it through constant iteration
doesn't matter if like the angle of a
table or this machine or like the
different knife that we use that we are
constantly iterating and constantly
collecting data to see like are we
producing a better product faster with
more quality so let me come back to the
USDA sure or maybe not directly USDA but
comparables and then we'll go from there
to
a sample night okay what the Run of show
looks like in the process and the reason
I want to talk about these two things is
that
in the field things are harder to
control than you would find in a
facility where you're using say cattle
shoots and so on
what does your
and people are not going to like some of
these words so apologies to those but I
think it's fascinating and important to
cover these things what does your say
kill efficiency or your sort of
measurements of Humane kill look like
compared to
sort of a conventional facility great
question and the reason I want to talk
about this
there are quite a few but one is that
I know that a decent portion of your
customer base is
vegans are vegetarians who make a soul
allowance for Maui venison yeah which is
maybe a sort of a head scratcher for a
lot of people so let's talk about sort
of your field
efficiency
compared to
what most people are indirectly
experiencing when they buy something
just wrapped in styrofoam yeah at their
local grocery store sure
part of the systems we had to build were
we had to follow the federal Meat
Inspection Act which the USDA is present
to make sure that animal is
supposed to be harvested humanely and
then that ultimately after that animal
is processed to make sure it's safe to
eat that's their two primary functions
and in a
and I know this hard for people to hear
but if you eat meat like it's
what it is in a typical brick and mortar
facility that animal is
coming in on a trailer moving through a
shoot system going into a press most
often so that animal is completely
stationary and then it's the language is
called rendered but it's then
essentially shot in the head so we had
to follow those exact same rules in the
field and with no control of the animal
the rules meaning Humane safe to eat yes
but not following that process but not
following that process yeah so we never
pen bait like we don't interact with
these animals at all prior to that
rendering or harvesting process they are
entirely wild and what we developed was
a
particular shooting system
that allows and or standardize our
Shooters to miss on purpose thirty
percent of the time and that sounds
weird but what it is is we are
essentially making sure every shot that
we hit that animal is perfect and
there's never any like outside injuries
and to do that if you shoot a two inch
group at 200 yards which is difficult to
do and you aim at the very very top or
tip of a head you are going to miss
about 30 of the time and so we actually
operate so just to yeah paint a visual
for people
so two inches it's a little bit bigger
than I say like a silver dollar yep so
imagine you have something that's
slightly bigger than a silver dollar and
you put it 600 feet away you need to put
every shot inside that yes silver dollar
that's what we're talking about yeah and
then you need to make sure your aim
point is in a place that never can
create injury because if you miss high
nothing happens that animal runs away
yep
and so we actually operate at about a
99.9 percent rendering efficiency and
what is the brick and mortar average 98
off of like thousands and thousands of
animals so we were able to meet and
exceed those guidelines or those rules
in the wild in the wild with animals
moving around yeah with a combination of
so you can imagine and this maybe like
leads into what like a night in the
field looks like but you have these Mad
Max looking utvs with four looking
infrared
screens essentially attached the USDA
inspector is sitting right beside you
the entire time and the technology is so
good that the heat the friction the
bullet makes passing through the air the
USD inspector is actually able to see
that bullet with the head of every
single animal
it's just an extraordinary process where
the animal is unaware that you're there
and so it is truly truly wild until the
second harvested and then dies
immediately yeah and so there's no
which like comes into play for nutrient
density there is no stress yeah they're
not flooded prior to harvesting and I
think when we get about like a message a
week from a vegan that says like I'm
finally able to come back to eating meat
because they understand why the animal
has to be managed and why that animal is
dying and then they agree and connect
strongly with that process like it's
truly the only stress-free
harvesting or Slaughter
of a animal within our food system
can you talk for a second about why this
is so rare right because people might
think well can't you just like go
hunting and sell the meat you cannot do
that yeah so what makes you able to do
this yeah great question for people who
don't have that background so a elk in
Montana
is a native species and it is owned by
the public right it's on publicly it's
on public land even on private land that
animal the management of that animal is
dictated by the state it is still owned
by got it the people right so an
invasive species on private land in
Hawaii is the liability and ownership of
the landowner so it is a very unique
situation in which you can actually like
do this process legally and it's only in
the instance where it is a invasive
species on private land we're not
allowed to operate on public land in
Hawaii so what and I bring this up
I mean obviously look I love Maui Nui
I'm an investor so of course I'm biased
but it all came down to and I think we
were initially introduced by Peter Tia
the quality just this pure quality
nutrient density of the product for me
yeah that's that's what it came down to
but I think as means of just educating
people about game meat and the sale of
game meat in general or let's just call
it sort of atypical proteins like
venison elk and so on
how much of the venison elk Etc that
people might buy at a Whole Foods or
something
is farmed 100 100
I bring this up just to say that like
people say you are what you eat that is
true but you're also like what you eat
yeah right so if let's say deer and Elk
is being fed
who knows corn feed and all sorts of
stuff and giving antibiotics potentially
it's very different from something that
is is wild harvested
so I don't want to skip too far ahead
let's talk about a night out just what
that looks like and then we'll talk
about
a nutrient profile
typical night for US starts at
10 p.m you can imagine a bunch of like
hyper local Hawaiians who I love getting
up like rolling out of bed we all sleep
on site we've got all these cubby holes
for them to sleep in we all sleep on
site we're getting up like making 10 p.m
10 p.m making dinner and breakfast
together like some of them are diesel
engines like you really gotta shake them
to get going
and we are constantly moving so we have
mobile facilities where we're moving
from site to site to do this process we
have these primary sites on all the
different ranches that we work with so
the first thing we're looking at each
evening is moving our mobile facilities
to another site to get closer to the
deer and the reason is one of the other
rules we have to follow is after that
animal is rendered it has to be back to
the facility cleaned processed without a
single hair on it in an hour yeah it's
it's pretty mind-boggling yeah so we'll
also link to a video that shows kind of
Snippets of this yeah that's on YouTube
because
if people think about that
I mean it's pretty mind-boggling and
maybe you can walk through how that's
accomplished so we're asking our team
members to be snipers
rally car drivers CrossFit athletes like
butchers
the people we have in our teams just
have these extraordinary skill sets it's
the funnest thing to watch a guy in his
first mix this year decathlates yeah
well we have to pick up every single one
of these animals and carry them on our
on our backs because you're not allowed
to drag them like you can either
introduce contaminants and or like
bruise the meat and it's actually one of
my favorite parts of the night is
it is the complete opposite of the rest
of the meat industry after you've
you know killed this animal for food
you're carrying this animal on your back
into its next stage of life with the
food and there's an individual
connection with each one of these
animals
and it's something that every guy on our
team like really takes pride in is being
able to like pick up these giant 250
pound animals across like razor sharp
lava or all like super 250 that's a big
boy you have these giant box
we're we're moving mobile Slaughter
facilities and we're getting all set up
and stage and you've got these like Mad
Max utvs and everything is getting ready
for what we call the performance period
and the USDA shows up and it is
essentially game time you have a finite
period of time which for a long time was
only three hours so you have all of the
variability of a wild animal and you
have to make it all work in a three hour
period like your entire business comes
down to like your mission business like
how you operate comes down to managing
variants within a three hour period so
nobody walks
everybody drives faster than they'd like
to
and we've never had more than like a cut
finger knock on wood and we expect just
extraordinary people and athletes to
come work with us we have had lots of
people that have come and been with us
for a week and said I can't do this like
I just I can't do this every night like
it's impossible so USDA comes we have
this very defined performance period
where we're going really really fast
under control and getting as many
animals as we can getting them back and
processing them and then before you know
it like the sun has come up and the
night is over and now just so we
understand some of the tools of the
trade that go into this so you're using
night vision scopes how is the
technology layered right to make this
work so the first piece of technology
that will start the night is these
forward-looking infrared drones so a
drone is going in there to give us a
picture of a couple thousand acres to
say like deer are going to be in these
areas as we get started
the forward-looking infrared binocular
system that we use I can tell you the
difference between a goat and a deer at
seven miles
so at 150 yards you can see like every
hair any abscess like the USDA being
able to say that animal is healthy is
achieved through that technology and
there's no lights on like it's
completely black deer has no idea what's
going on as they're being like evaluated
by the USDA and then the shooters also
have forward-looking infrared scopes so
you never have to introduce light into
the scenario to to scare them and that's
what allows you to like Harvest enough
animals every night to make it work so
you come up over a hill
you see a couple deer all of the lights
go off all of this forward-looking
infrared equipment comes on instantly so
the USDA is able to view it he's able to
look at those five animals and say yeah
you're able to take those animals and he
has to like verbally like we need to
wait he has to verbally say those things
oftentimes you can shoot several of
those animals because
they don't actually know what's going on
it's the middle of the night and the
minute they don't feel safe they just
run so you know you're still harvesting
them under stress-free conditions if
they're just standing there half the
time they'll go back to feeding
animals are rendered properly they go
down immediately and as soon as our
shooter says clear and the USDA is clear
people are like sprinting into the
bushes to find these animals again it's
the middle of the night if the grass is
four feet tall we have laser pointer
systems that come off of the utvs to
like show them the right direction
and animal gets picked up brought back
to the UTV and then we'll collect a
couple of them
we have a roving team they're called so
we have a team of Rovers that
essentially are the Mad Max Team where
they all collect a couple deer and then
they'll move as fast as they can back to
where the mobile Slaughter and like
processing facilities or station and so
they're just cycling back and forth
between the harvesting team and the
processing teams so it's this is
intricate dance and this is all at night
on this is not paved roads these are
like rough off-road scenarios and so one
of my favorite things to do is the first
week we train somebody
we have a course that they have to run
and we let them run the Course once and
it takes typically takes like seven
minutes and we're like we need to do
that in three minutes and they're just
like what like we need to do that in
three minutes or you were not gonna get
back in time
so it's always fun to sit in that seat
and we have these very specialized ucbs
that are essentially impossible to tip
over
but it is so fun to watch these
amazing local guys develop all these
incredible skill sets and they just like
every morning the sun comes up and
everybody's just like grinning ear to
ear it's very much feels like a sports
team and obviously with like my history
I run it kind of like a sports team and
the coach and just
an amazing experience to do one of these
hunks yeah so just to Define terms also
if if people don't know what UTV means
it's kind of like a super tactical Mad
Max golf cart there you go it's a bit
larger yeah right yeah so people may
have seen like Polaris as one brand name
there are many others there are other
terms used to refer to these things but
that's what we're talking about yeah
so
what are some of the other keys to
selecting or building
a team like you have built because
you're asking a lot of these people yeah
and it's an unusual work culture right
so what are some of your framework
systems criteria for hiring but also
training once people are
yeah in the position
great people already being there to
train great people like really really
goes a long way
and we can talk about kind of that
system we built later if you want but
the communication
and people being patient is probably the
most important thing you have to imagine
you're doing almost everything through
radios so you sound like Kermit the Frog
all night long and you don't like you
only catch half of it sometimes but
you're moving really fast and the
expectation is like you keep moving fast
and so somebody has to be patient enough
when like oh I didn't get that message
or I didn't know what to like
communication is so key when you can't
see body language you can't hear
properly and everybody's operating out
of a head lamp so you have this little
10 degree view of what you can see
through light I'm sure it's the most
critical thing in like a lot of
businesses but when you are operating
like that at night it just Amplified
skill that if you don't have we just we
get on it so fast and communication how
do you get on it so I've never had a
hard time having hard conversations so I
would talk to people about tone and
approaches and different words they
could use like
reminder instead of get this thing done
like we really focus on individual
language and then we basically built
a language of harvesting so we have all
of these keywords so people don't get
confused with what's going on so we've
created kind of our own Harvest language
that allows people not to get confused
when we're going really fast and then
ultimately we built a system called HHS
which stands for humble hunger smart and
is largely based on humble hungry okay
this is a Canadian yeah yeah and it's
largely based on a book that Patrick
Lencioni wrote called the ideal team
player and it is a
peer-to-peer
evaluation system that measures humility
work ethic and emotional intelligence
and it was it became so important for us
to have the right people
the biggest risk we have every single
night is safety and it became so
critically important to have the right
people and the right personalities that
we had to build a system to measure
those personalities and that's in the
recruiting vetting process oh yeah how
do you measure those things humility
we created essentially a scorecard it
has six questions per category so six
for humility six for work ethic six four
emotional intelligence questions like do
the energy they bring every night is it
consistent as in it positive so
we talk about body language and
emotional intelligence and all these
different things within these questions
and I'm happy to like provide this thing
and we use it in three ways
we give it to the person on the second
interview and we're hiring somebody so
we say here's the HHS system this is the
only thing you're accountable to in your
first month and two things happen they
read it and they go
or actually they just don't call back
and I've made a ton of hiring mistakes
in the past where
you get past this honeymoon phase and
people turn into grouches and yeah
there's people personalities and balls I
remember a guy that we were going to
hire that was on a like brilliant
electrical engineer who wanted to quit
his job come work with us because you
heard about the seven and seven schedule
and thought it'd be the best thing ever
and then he read it and he didn't call
me back
and I I really wanted to hire him and
and I called him back and I said any
reason you didn't call me back he's like
I have terrible body language and I'm
not willing to quit my job and take the
chance within the first month that I get
fired for bad body language because we
score them if you're an a we celebrate
and figure out a way for you reward you
if you're a b we like find immediate
improvements that you need to make
within some of these categories and if
you are a c we let you go on the spot no
questions asked
and when you set that expectation up
front oh so we said that in the
interview they have to like agree to
this system coming in they're evaluated
by their entire team including them
doing a self eval which is a part of the
overall score they get to like grade
themselves and the team do they are they
sent on like a test evening
prior to hiring or I guess they just
know that once they start going out yeah
so we call them tryouts but when
somebody comes to try out with us which
means we give them a month we we hire
them on but we call them a tryout and at
the end of that tryout which is
typically a one month period they get
graded by their entire team and they
know it's this like really tense moment
where how many people are on a given
team eight to ten got it yeah so it's a
good average so if somebody yeah if
somebody's got to bug up their ass about
somebody just one person it it always
ends up being like a great average and
it always ends up being a great measure
of that person it's been this
extraordinary filter for hiring
asshole's the wrong word but when we
figured out how to use that system we
now grade every person at their first
month we grade every single person
quarterly including me every single
person gets graded and there's questions
on there like do they try or ask to do
more than is required of them every day
and it's been so amazing to see the
mistakes I make in when we're hiring new
people or moving people around like a
great example is
I moved a couple people from a field
position into a management position and
then all of a sudden their work ethic
score started coming down and it wasn't
because they weren't working any harder
it was I didn't do a good job defining
to the team what their new
responsibilities were so they saw them
sitting on a computer and doing these
things and they're like well they're not
in the field helping us and so it's just
this amazing quarterly exercise that
just pulls out all of the tension within
your teams and creates framework for
people to address those tensions and
then ultimately what's amazing is to
watch people grow
how do you give feedback let's say they
come back and they've got a bunch of
bees what's the big boss do yeah so we
sit them down and we say
is that the Royal way or is it just you
no no it's it's multiple people yeah
it's me and like the two or three other
Harvest managers got it
great example one of the questions we
asked talks about do they are they
genuinely happy to see their teammates
succeeding because safety is such an
important part of what we do when we
bring somebody in that's more talented
just like a sports team moves the best
people into the best positions we
immediately move people around positions
based on their skill sets so somebody
has to be genuinely happy to train
somebody that may replace them in a role
that they may enjoy yeah they used to be
the yeah like right Striker or whatever
exactly got replaced and it's amazing to
watch somebody that really wants to be
there because they find purpose and they
really love the schedule and they know
the impact that they're having to our
community have to make the decision
to be better for their teammate every
night to be like celebrating that
person's growth even though it's
potentially coming at the cost of
something that they enjoy yeah so
there's these that's hard oh I mean I'm
not saying it's unreasonable but that I
mean that's that's asking a lot of a lot
of people and I don't know if I would be
honest with myself I think that'd be
hard here's the thing like it's been
such a amazing exercise with lots of
iterations right yeah like the first
three iterations I made so many grown
men cry and I felt so bad
was that your delivery or the
measurement were you just like it was
just the ambition [__] face it was the
measurement was wrong no you're getting
evaluated by your peers on your
personality and the value it's bringing
to your team yeah and you have to sit
down quarterly and like be told
your humility is not good enough for
this team I assume that the responses
are all anonymized yeah everything's
anonymized so and then average for what
it's worth so I've done what's called a
360 interview right and I know people
who as Executives or Founders have had
these done and
without exception and myself included
every time that I spoke to somebody
who's experienced this for the first
time they're like I went and they sat in
my car oh and I basically had like a
nervous breakdown crisis of meaning
what do I do
like these are names everybody would
recognize but they were just like
holy [__] yeah the first time we did it
with a large enough team that I included
myself in it because we were just so
small early on it was I think like the
third iteration I was like I need to be
a part of this and I got all of the
feedback back I was just like oh my God
but if we really want to build
extraordinary teams like I realized my
approach to some of our conversations
yeah had to be
so much better and nuanced to make to
make them better and like it wasn't the
right approach and you learn all of this
you end up reading this thing like
Braille after doing it I've done it like
hundreds of times now yeah and I mean
with repetition I imagine yeah that's
like exercise right it's like okay
you're gonna do Plyometrics once a year
you're you're gonna be very very very
sore yeah and you might even hurt
yourself but if you're doing it but it
was amazing to see what happens we built
this system because we knew we had to go
from like eight people to 45 in a really
short period of time to hit our mission
goals about a year and a half ago and
I had made poor hiring decisions in the
past and they were mostly
personality based or they were that
person was operating
amazing when I was around but the minute
I left they turned into a different
person and then there's this he said she
said game this completely erases all of
that yeah because it's Anonymous team
scoring and the manager doesn't have a
unweighted vote on whether that person
stays around and what ended up happening
is we that HHS program started
attracting people they started hearing
about this accountability process to
ensure you're attracting better fits oh
yeah so coming back to so you're not
saying Hey [__] face yeah in like the
fourth fifth 10th 20th iteration yeah
what's the language that you use
if somebody has growth opportunities
that's great it's really specific to
which of the 18 categories they're
struggling in right like how does the
meeting start okay so we sit down and we
we're gonna give them paper and we say
like okay you're a B minus Yeah Tim we
put a 250 pound animal on your back you
crumpled into an origami crane and you
couldn't get up so you're a B minus and
then we celebrate first some of the
categories that they're doing really
well in like some of the categories that
point to professionalism or energy or
all these different things we celebrate
right away because they're each one of
the 24 segments have different scores
within them that have been averaged
throughout their team and then we
address the ones that they're like a c
in and
a great example a lot of our young guys
that come on board got it so they're not
cut if they have a c in a particular
Viewpoint it's the average yeah so the C
average and it's been amazing to see
that system work
I've let go several people that were C's
that I would have never let go
I wouldn't have known to let them go
yeah like wouldn't have known that that
was the impact they were having on the
team at large it just would have never
come out yeah I would love to you
mentioned I think you offered to maybe
share oh absolutely question so we'll
put that in the show notes as well yeah
team.blog podcast because I'm I'm
incredibly curious to check it out
myself it just at least at face value
it seems like a very elegant solution to
a lot of problems that can seem like
fragmented separate problems you have to
address in different ways I've Heard
lots of people's
and again like I'm just a system builder
and by no means is it perfect but I've
heard lots of people speak to how
important these different personality
traits are and how they reward them and
more importantly than the c or the A's
being able to like say to somebody this
incredible combination of like humility
work ethic and emotional intelligence is
making your whole team better yeah and
your whole team is telling you you're
extraordinary ethnic things being able
to reward and compensate somebody for
that and have a measure to do so you say
compensate so let's say they have
because I know this is getting the weeds
yeah bit but I feel like yep that's
where a lot of the good stuff is hiding
so
how many questions were there again
there's 18 questions six on humility six
on work ethic and six on emotional
intentions and they get this like a b or
c for each of those questions there it's
graded one through seven yeah we just
did it because it was seven days of the
week and we talk about like being at
excellent every day
so it's one through seven and then we
add up all the scores which is 126 total
and they get a percentage so if they're
in 87 we give them a B plus which is the
average which is the average how do you
reward or compensate the A's if they're
in their first sixth month of employment
and they get two like A's or a pluses in
a reward we give them a raise based on
that contribution and then we celebrate
with the team like
no was it was an a this last quarter
like we make sure the team knows the
contribution that they're having and
it's already which is so interesting
they already all know yeah right but to
not have framework to reward them for
being amazing people has always been
this fuzzy place for me where I couldn't
like
reward or compensate that person for
being an extraordinary individual that
was making their whole team better
because it didn't fit into what the
classic hard skills Define as like
they're a great shooter or they're a
great driver or one of these different
things and every single one of those a
plus people are our most highly skilled
people as well when you operate with a
certain level of humility you are more
willing to learn yeah right and you
learn faster yeah and every single
person that's come through our program
that was like a B minus or a c that was
like highly skilled and made the choice
not to get better at these but I very
much consider like skills just weeded
themselves out yeah yeah it's been it's
been really cool to see people grow and
like you're in this camp and you see
these guys with their their a lot of
them will tape their score
up above their bed
and they'll like look at it in the
morning and say like okay my job is to
make I was a B minus in this thing I
need to bring more consistent energy
overnight we've got guys that go up and
down and up and down and they're like
okay I'm gonna be trying to be more
consistent like they know what they're
working on you know this gave me a
flashback because when I was in high
school and I wasn't a particularly I
just for whatever reason I mean I
trained my ass off but I was not the
most gifted wrestler
but I was pretty tough and
not 10 out of 10 tough but I ended up
reading this book
it's I'm sure dated in a million ways
but it was called mental toughness
training for sports and there was an
assessment and it was actually not that
I think about it pretty similar to HHS
and I gave the assessment to like five
or six people and they did the
assessment and then I took my score and
that became my reminder cool and that is
when in a single season I mean I went
from kind of middle of the pack to
almost entirely undefeated until the
very end of the season yeah and it's not
because I was the most gifted but it's
it's in part due to having a constant
reminder that is not from one person
right you spot patterns we're like okay
if it were just one person I could maybe
dismiss it but now now I'm getting this
from multiple people I respect
it works man it really works
and you could do this I'm just
Thinking Out Loud obviously I was gonna
say he's talking out loud but that's
they're redundant I'm just talking out
loud here folks but you could use this
outside of an employment context right
like you could take oh this HHS and give
it to
five to ten people you know and just ask
them to be yep honest like that's the
prereq I'm not asking you to be nice I'm
asking you to be accurate and I want to
give credit where it's do Patrick
lencioni's an amazing like the book the
ideal team player which is what a lot of
the ques like the questions aren't based
on it but this idea that
the original name humble hungry smart is
from that book and so when somebody
comes in they have to read that book and
it gives them the base principles of
what we're talking about and then we
basically design the questions and yeah
it's been incredible like you get young
25 year olds that come in and their
first couple of weeks they're sitting in
a meeting and they're hunched over and
like they got their hood on and
typically that's a
that's a hard conversation to have with
somebody to say like I need you to sit
up take your hood off like be an active
listener because it's an uncomfortable
thing to like talk to somebody about
their body language and you get to do
that immediately because the team has
framework and language to say like Hey
listen brother in three weeks you're
gonna get graded one of those things is
body language and if you just sit up in
the meeting take your hood off and make
sure like you're looking at the person
talking about you're gonna get a better
score we like you we want to keep you
around yeah yeah like if you happen to
come in late up front like it's not
impromptu improvise it gives them the
ability to have hard conversations when
somebody rolls in a little bit late
which is already unacceptable but if
they don't like genuinely apologize
somebody gets to come to them and say
like one of our questions is about being
like genuine about your apologies if
you've made mistakes and we're allowed
to make mistakes here we make a lot but
like you come in and being like oh sorry
guys like don't do that next time and it
will be better yeah so it's outside of
me it's given everybody else framework
to have uncomfortable conversations and
or celebrate people right so the ideal
team player lension this is a signed
reading yeah this is an assigned reading
do you have any other assigned reading
not for field teams we have them focus
on that one for sure we've got for some
of our other staff we have Confessions
of a pricing man
simin I think is the last read that book
it's really good I have like a lot of
anybody that deals with any type of like
product strategy and make sure they read
that one I haven't thought of that book
in a long time oh it's so good and then
the The Road Less stupid
okay I don't know this one it is one of
my favorite like General business books
and um drawn a blank on the it's okay
it's memorable I've read a lot actually
Chris ashington recommended it to me
obviously those who don't know Chris
action is the founder of ag1 previously
athletic greens yeah he's been an
amazing okay he's always handed me
homework he's a great operator yeah
so
again and happy to share like all of the
questions and I think when people see
the questions you can actually they're
tailored to our teams but it's actually
pretty easy to tailor those questions to
your specific work format I haven't
quite found a way to move them into like
the virtual Zoom world because a lot of
them are so tactile in how people work
together in workflows and there will be
several iterations we just changed it
again but in its current format and
framework I think it could be valuable
to people and happy to share yeah we'll
put it in the show notes for folks to
check out I promised it earlier so I
want to not be remiss and come back to
it as this conversational Boomerang
returns to me
nutrient density got it how should we
tackle this where would you like to
start
we could start at when this is true for
plants yeah also true for meat anything
you put in your mouth
has a certain composition and just
because it's called the same thing
banana banana banana yeah right green
bean green bean green bean does not mean
they are equal in nutritional value
I'll start at maybe the end I think
nutrient density I.E food quality
and being able to measure that
accurately and someone be able to
understand it in its simplest form I.E
on a label is going to completely change
our food system and
be the lever for regenerative
agriculture meaning having an indicator
on a label some type of measurement just
like you look at calories just like you
walked into a store tomorrow and you
flipped it over and there was two
blueberries and one said 92 and one said
76. and you that 92 meant that was that
much better for you measuring thousands
of biochemicals that they now can
through metabolomic testing
you're gonna buy the one
and what's so amazing about the
conversation of nutrient density is that
is nutrition of place
and when you think of regenerative
agriculture practices which is basically
just layering conservation practices
like we're taking care of soil we're
taking care of water we're doing these
different things which people have done
for a long time in certain cultures and
we got away for for a long time and now
we're coming back to it and if you knew
the quality of your food not measured by
the five metrics that are currently
available but measured by the thousands
of biochemicals that we can now test for
both good and bad and that became and
there's
billions of dollars going into this like
the Patagonia Provisions are like this
is coming for sure and what was really
interesting for us is we got to be one
of the first people to be fully tested
so
about two years ago
we submitted our bone broth to a typical
USDA fsns lab to to make our label and I
remember them yeah they called me and
they said something's wrong with these
bones
I was like
we sent you like the bone broth they
were made from regular bones they they
had thought we had put like a some form
of like protein powder or additional
collagen in there because it tested 33
percent higher in protein per ounce than
anything they'd ever seen so they had to
like retest it and it came out the exact
same way yeah and our mission was never
nutrient density our mission was to
balance populations and I always knew it
was better for me because that animal
had a choice to eat but when we got that
testing we were like wait a second like
what is going on here so we sent livers
and hearts and different cuts into a
conventional lab for testing sure enough
lab emails me in the middle of it I
remember this one they're like
there's something wrong with the hearts
they have too much choline there's
nothing wrong we just sent you a heart
and we were working with
did you introduce us to Anthony Gustin
ooh doctor at we got to Anthony Gustin I
don't think so but I do know okay I know
who he is absolutely he's helped other
people I know we were trying to figure
out and compare after we got that
information to
a typical comparison to beef and what he
pointed us to which was crazy and scary
is the vast majority of the USDA
databases from the 1930s I wonder if I
made that intro it's possible you've
made a lot of them my friends yeah I
appreciate it but what we found out is
that the nutritional comparison to beef
weren't even actually able to do it
because the data was so dated and you're
able to be off to within 20 on a label
which is a whole other story anyway
people who are packaging things have
more wiggle room than a lot of consumers
20 wiggle room yeah it's wild up or down
whichever one favors them yeah yeah so
Dr Gustin introduced us to somebody Dr
Van Vleet at Utah State University who
has probably been one of the most
advanced food labs in North America and
he was doing the largest beef study ever
done and the most in-depth measuring a
thousand plus biochemicals through
disadvanced metabolomic testing and we
just happened to get like tossed in at
the end of it so there's like 200 plus
espritive access deer so there's 200
plus beef samples and then they threw us
at the end and he thought like oh this
will be really cool to see an animal
that has a choice to what it eats
what that might look like in a
what we understood as a fairly fertile
area right okay so
comes out two to four x the
phytochemicals so all of the good stuff
from plants that gets transferred into
meat
were two to four x were
8 to 64x the Omega-3s every single
category was absurd and then
probably the most exciting for me is
they measured oxidative stress so the
stress in animal goes through during
that process you can measure that
oxidative stress and its impact on
there's a whole bunch of chemicals I
still don't understand I'm not a
nutritionist but they were able to
measure the negative impacts of stress
and of course ours was essentially zero
and the cattle the beef stuff was all
over the place it was it was pretty
scary but when I saw it the most
exciting thing honestly wasn't Maui Nui
it was
a this is nutrition of place
this is a direct reflection of how well
and how fertile a place is because all
of that nutrient density is coming from
the plants that they're eating and I.E
the soil yeah and the health of the
water moving through the soil and
instantly realized if every consumer had
this level of insight
into the nutritional quality of their
food it'll completely change the way
people look at that food system and then
it'll change the entire sort of supply
chain well it's not a race to the bottom
anymore of producing Commodities which
is like the most you can at the cheapest
price I mean this is my favorite saying
like when Every Time Peter and tia says
we're overnourished I'm just like yes
like we just have we're producing an
absurd amount of calories that aren't
good for us yeah it's coming and we're
gonna understand like the nutritional
quality of our food and it will be
graded and easy to know and that will
create these direct relationships with
these what will probably be regenerative
Agri like practices that are fostering
the health of these places and then so
when we dug even further we found out
that
the leeward slopes of volcanic as
Leeward mean it is the windward side of
a slope got it yeah
Hawaii Haleakala has a very
particular soil called andesols
and then there are three types of
andosols andosols are some of the most
fertile soils in the world they hold
water better and hold more nutrients
from those Waters better and then of the
three soil types of the three endosal
soil types we have one called a u-stand
and it's the most fertile of the three
so the slopes were harvesting these deer
on
are actually I think the U stands make
up point zero five percent of the
world's soils that's wild so we happen
to be luck of the draw yeah and that's
the thing it again like this was never
our mission the mission was just to
balance populations but we happen to
have one of the most virile animals in
the world that has a choice to like eat
exactly what it wants moving through the
most fertile slopes maybe on the planet
and I think that's what Dr Van vleip got
so excited about is he now has a marker
to say
when there's an extremely fertile place
that's like
for most part well taken care of in a
lot of the areas because they're able to
go to the very best areas this is what
nutrient density could look like and
it's you know two to like vitamin A was
800 times in the liver versus some of
these beef livers so to come back to one
point
the DHA I don't know if there's EPA in
Exeter I have no idea I'm not a
lipidologist I think there is yeah yeah
so on the omega-3 side is eating access
deer
in terms of levels of Omega-3s I guess
we'd have to think about the sort of
concentration per ounce but is it
comparable to
eating some types of fish or would it
still be significantly lower well we
don't know the answer to that yet
because the study measured it in
comparison to beef right so the
percentages and so on were benchmarked
to beef so the new piece of equipment
that Dr Bradley has coming in will be
able to give us measures in milligrams
micrograms like we'll know that in the
near future here and this is what
ultimately there's several companies
working on this it audacious is one of
them is amazing company like they're
going to be able to measure these
thousands of biochemicals to
the form that you need to turn them into
a label but we know to answer your
question we know even in comparison to
beef it is about halfway to Salmon so
it's actually a significant source of
Omega-3s that for some people that don't
eat fish like it it goes a long way yeah
yeah so okay A little inside
joke because before we press record we
were talking about some very very
well-known professional sports teams
yeah who are using Maui Nui to feed
their players and some of these players
for whatever reason I just want to fish
but they will eat now I know well and
they blood tests every week these
extraordinary athletes and we've just
started working with a lot of these
Sports nutritionists and they're going
to be able to measure for us if it's
having an impact on these athletes
that's so cool again like never part of
the mission for us but an understanding
of place and this is what gets cool I
mean like my wife's so excited she's
like
this comes back to that conversation of
like Innovation is a culture and
Hawaiians were able to produce
extraordinary like nutrient-rich foods
with finite resources for a million
people and Hawaii now Imports 95 of its
food and half of its Twinkie level like
nutritional value
it really points back to our places in
farming what we're doing and it's it's
really fun to have such a strong
connection to place and it helped to
inform Your solution
so connection to place you have kuhulani
you have the little ones oh yeah right
you live in Hawaii
let's talk about the family for a second
oh clawback allowances oh man I get to
give you credit for this wait till you
hear this one yeah okay okay fire away
John list yep you know okay I was just
thinking about you John list the
economist you had on the show and he was
talking about using clawback allowances
in a professional format but I remember
him talking about using it to potty
train his kids yeah and this idea of
loss aversion I.E like I already have it
and you're gonna take it away from me
being much stronger than the opposite
like how hard will you work to make
fifty dollars versus how hard will you
work if you feel like fifty dollars has
been taken away exactly so the latter we
had been struggling with equals a lot
more allowances for the kids yeah and we
make lots of mistakes as parents and
what the allowances were accidentally or
doing where they were training them they
had jobs and they did their jobs and
then they earned their money if they did
their jobs but what what it was doing is
when we asked them to do extra stuff and
be helpful it was like well I'm gonna am
I gonna make more money yeah and we had
taught them this system that
was the opposite of what we were trying
to teach them which was to try and be
helpful yeah and me and cool I remember
that like I remember her listening to it
like
six hours later than I did and she's
like did you hear about the clawback
allowance I was like yes and we both
thought of it instantly like let's do it
for allowances and so what we do now and
we change two things we put twenty
dollars in ones on the fridge at the
beginning of the month and we say this
is yours
and what we do now is we claw back those
dollar bills for attitude instead of
jobs so what we do is when we say can
you go feed the dogs and he's like oh we
just walk to the fridge and we pull off
a dollar
was this amazing exercise over a period
of three months to like it was straight
Revolt like what are you talking about
like Mutiny on the ship and Revolt
turned into like a little bit of sarcasm
like yeah fine I'll do that because they
wanted they didn't want to lose their
money yeah one step back they don't get
we don't buy them anything yeah we're
kind of strict when it comes to like
they get stuff at birthdays and they get
stuff at Christmas but other than that
like they need to be useful people and
earn their money yeah and so they really
value
that like the dollars they get at the
end of the month and it went from
Mutiny to sarcasm and I remember it
happening and I remember like asking Leo
who to grab the laundry and she's like
sure and I was like
wait a second I looked like who was like
that to actually just work and then
don't get me wrong don't get me wrong
they're amazing kids they're 99 they're
the kids yeah they're little humans and
now like uh just a couple weeks ago I
came home and like public was like I
just I cleaned the car and I was like
huh what's wrong with you like it was
just awesome
thing that like a combination of the
clawback allowance and training for
attitude instead of them earning for a
task yeah was this this if it helps
anybody again we're not amazing parents
by any means but like I think you're
pretty good parents that's what I can
tell small trick yeah oh boy yeah it's
been a big one for us for sure so I'm
gonna toggle around a little bit here I
have some notes in front of me so we're
talking about the kids yeah
secret Pinterest boards oh man this is
another one
for the relationship between you and
your wife yeah all right I know you're
not allowed to talk about it but it's
just me and you yeah just us sitting
this table well I've actually not
Millions I've actually tried to talk
about this with a couple of our friends
and this is like Fight Club level like
you don't talk about this so exclusive
here first yeah it's Tim Ferriss show so
much of my credit goes to my amazing
wife but all of the credit for this one
goes to her
and you have to follow the rules of this
one or it doesn't work so early on in
our relationship I think I'm two years
in
she's an extraordinary person have no
idea what to buy for her I've failed
several several times like she barely
will spend a hundred dollars on herself
a couple times a year right so she's
that type of person she thrifts 99 of
her clothes et cetera et cetera so it's
just like the worst person ever to try
and buy stuff for she's so picky and
she sits me down I give her a birthday
gift I get it all wrong
she sits me down the next day and she's
like this is what we're gonna do
a we're never going to talk about this
conversation again and B I've created a
secret Pinterest board that I've invited
you to every item on there is something
that I want it's exactly what I want it
like the link goes exactly to it but
here's how this works you are never
allowed to talk about this and you're
never allowed to give it for like give
it to me for like a birthday or
something it weren't bigger and
birthdays anyways and she's like I will
pretend
that you did it in every single City no
this is the most important part okay
yeah right my children think I'm a
genius
like
they all come home and they'll just be
like this random box on the table that
has these beautiful earrings in them and
cool will come in and she'll just be
like oh my God how did you know like
this is exactly what I wanted I can't
believe you found them I've been looking
for them forever and and my girls will
look at me like how it's just amazing
dad like how did you know she does it so
well half the time I think like
oh my God I'm amazing I'm like like she
she has fake cried several times she
does it in front of her mom she did like
the only way this works is I believe
half the time that I've done this
amazing thing for like that's how
important it is yeah and it has been the
greatest
like I never ever think about buying her
anything anytime I even like have the
slightest inclination I go straight to
the Pinterest board and I just grab one
thing off of it and it shows up and she
does this amazing job of like it's the
biggest deal your dad's the most amazing
person from being able to like figure
this thing out and they all believe it
and we're never allowed to tell anybody
about a secret oh it is so she's done it
in front of couples
and the guys are just like how did you
know I'm like I just I just pay
attention man I just figure it out
and like it just makes me look so good
and she gets exactly what she wants yeah
and we never like I tried to bring it up
once when their mom was around and she
looked at me like she was gonna kill me
she's just like we don't talk about it
or else it goes away and it doesn't work
you know the rules oh man bite your
tongue it's so good she has to pretend
it's real and
I feel amazing
a win-win yeah oh win win win win win on
so many levels all right so I'm gonna
let you choose where we go next okay
old lady crying on the couch game
or a tug of war okay I will
I'm gonna stick with the my wife's a
genius one here and we'll give her the
old lady on the couch game all right
and I didn't ask about it till recently
she for years
has
done this thing and I didn't know what
it was
when things when she was frustrated or
something was going on she would like
close her eyes and like instantly turn
into the happiest person in the world
and like be loving our kids even if they
were monsters and I didn't know I didn't
know what was happening
and so I finally asked her I was like
okay what is that thing here doing and
she's like that's my old lady crying on
the coach game and I'm like what the
like what is that and she said
when I'm feeling frustrated with my kids
I pretend I'm 80 years old
and she and she's amazing like she
really like closes her eyes and she
pretends she's 80 years old and she says
I'm given the opportunity it's my
birthday or something and I'm given the
opportunity to use a time machine
but I am only allowed to go back to this
exact moment
and she really does it like she closes
her eyes and she opens her eyes and
she's 80 and she has five minutes to be
this 80 year old lady looking at her
nine-year-old daughter again after she's
been growing up and she can open her
eyes and she just like stands up and
she's like oh my she's so cute and she
kisses their face and the kids know what
the game is yeah and there's like oh Mom
you're doing that thing again like but
she genuinely can put herself in the
place of gratitude to be back in that
moment
seeing her kids again after 30 or 40
Years of them being grown and old and
watching her do it is amazing and then I
I have tried it several times since she
told me and if you really put yourself
in that situation I've done it with my
son he's turning 14 and he's got like
hair under like it's happening puberty
is happening like it's happening right
and I only have four more years with him
until he graduates
and a couple times I found myself
frustrated with him I closed my eyes and
I think like when I'm 80 and my knees
are sore and like what would I feel to
be able to go back and see him at 14
when he's in this place you're a
self-care deity is amazing if you're
just like when I'm 80 and my knee starts
and I got Peter t as my friend so but
it's just she's a genius yeah like in
some of the most frustrating moments
kids are like your greatest joy and
they're will frustrate you more than
anybody in the planet can and she's just
found this way to have gratitude for
that time because it's gone
and she calls it like old lady crying on
the couch game because she cries she'll
like be tearing up and the kids will be
like oh God here we go again because
they get kissed all over the face and
like oh you're so small and cute and
it's amazing and like yeah she's she's
amazing at finding ways to be grateful
for her so this really gratefully
brought this up because it reminded me
of something that I found super valuable
for
a couple of years and then as often
happens I just kind of forgot about it
which was for tribe of mentors so my
last book there were many people
featured and one of the questions I
asked almost everybody was when you were
feeling overwhelmed or frustrated
what do you do
and one of the answers was
when I'm feeling overwhelming or
frustrated
I look at whatever this mundane
situation is and I'll give a personal
example like if I'm laying in a hammock
and not necessarily I could be
frustrated or preoccupied by something
but like my dog Molly's playing with a
stick and I'm just kind of chilling I
ask myself like 50 years from now how
much would I pay to come back to this
moment
for just 10 minutes
right similar trick right but I haven't
used it it's so good and this is the
perfect reboot yeah so thank you oh yeah
she's again she gets vast majority of
the credit for anything that's smart
that comes out of my mouth
tug of war okay this one Ricky Elias
founder of Red Ventures introduced to me
through Peter gets all the credit but it
was so good it's something that I
started doing that I have to share and
he described this the last parenting one
I promise he described parenting as a
tug of war you have to lose
okay and it's really interesting when
you have kids and you like hold on to
them I've Heard lots of different
parenting advice and the one the reason
it stuck with me so well is it's such a
great visual of your kids pulling a line
across from you and that line moving
through your hands
so when they're two and three years old
you don't even have to hold it you're
just like whatever you can't pull that
thing like and then they get like six or
seven and they give it like a little tug
and you're like oh well I gotta hold on
to this thing and then the best part
about that advice is knowing you have to
lose so knowing when they're 18 or 19
you have to have fully let go of that
rope
and the visual that comes to my mind all
the time is just this really slow steady
release of that rope instead of like
these giant jumps or like these
parenting mistakes that like you're not
letting them become independent and
responsible and
useful
you're trying to teach them all of these
things so that you can let go of the
Rope at the end of it and
they're okay you're trying to like
spare them the feeling of being useless
how does that impact that metaphor or
analogy how did that affect how you
parent or make decisions good example
Leo who asked for her like first
sleepover which would be pretty
stringent about
because
she like wants to go an hour away and
sleep in a house and I would like my
immediate reaction was
no
and then the thought in my head was like
wait a second she's 12. and if you're
gonna like let go of the Rope up a
little bit this is probably the right
situ like you're gonna have to let it
all the way go this is probably the
right situation to like Let It Go a
little bit make sure it's safe and you
call the parents and you figure out what
it is but like it reminds me the best
actionable use of it is knowing you have
to let it like knowing it has to be gone
you have to do it eventually so like do
you want to let go of 20 feet at once
yeah why not and like they fall flat on
their ass yeah
or do you want to like gradually let it
go so it's okay and just the idea of
seeing it moving through your hands and
knowing you don't want it to be this
sudden jerk has made it easier for me to
make those small decisions knowing at
1819 hopefully we'll see they're gone
right and they'll always be mine are
ours but
it's one of the few parenting advice
I've ever heard that created like an
actionable thing where I said like okay
I need to make this slow and smooth and
the right transition for them so thank
you Rick it's been it was a good one
amazing so I want to ask just as we
start coming to a close a few questions
one is
what are your hopes and dreams for the
next few years and I want you to also
answer something
which is one of the questions you may
not remember this but it was very
important question for me me to ask very
early on which was
something along the lines of how do you
ensure that you do not over Harvest
or end up doing more more damage than
good because people respond to
incentives if this economic model works
if the product is very very high quality
which it is if there is a lot of demand
how do you ensure that you're not
seduced by the Sirens of capitalism and
end up becoming something antithetical
to your current ethos yeah so maybe that
ties in just in terms of rules
objectives that you've set for
yourselves yeah as a company but broadly
speaking also hopes and goals over the
next few years okay so I'll answer the
second first in that our mission is to
achieve balance and defining balance we
don't actually get to do that which is
probably really important so we have the
tools to make sure we can measure like
we talked about during surveys we have
the tools to make sure we measure really
accurately how many we're harvesting and
the impact it's having but the
individual landowners ultimately make
that decision and in the community at
large gets to weigh in as well through
public lands and so if we've done our
job really well
deer will find a place within our food
systems not within our like critical
ecosystems that collect water and not at
densities that impact our reefs they
will
they will find a way into our food
systems in these mid elevations and the
ranchers are already pointing to that
they get to decide what densities they
want and they can only have densities
that are healthy I.E they grow enough
grass that those animals are healthy and
sustainable we get to be the tool to
help find balance we actually don't get
to answer the question which is the
guarding agent between us doing more
harm than good they get to make that
decision which is awesome the community
gets to make that decision and there'll
be some ranchers that decide
ranches or grass Farmers right there'll
be some ranchers that decide I'm not
doing cattle anymore I want more deer in
this area but we have the tool to manage
them the same way they would a cattle
herd and that's really My Hope for what
we're doing at mauinui is we find the
balance that's best for
all of our communities ecosystem
communities food system communities are
like human communities near shore
fisheries and the great part about what
we've talked about today is
where there's just so much iteration to
what we do and it's so variable that
it's the infinite game for us that we're
just gonna keep doing it every single
year trying to find balance because some
years you'll have more rain some years
you won't and will constantly be able to
go back to our community and say like
how is this working what does this look
like
and I think maybe that's the like
balance is maybe my hope for
Life as a whole and like personal goals
I don't have
this is not a multi-billion Dollar
business for us like I'm so content we
already loved the place that we're in
like I don't need bigger brighter
shinier things if I've done a great job
letting go that rope really slowly and
collectively like we've talked about
today growing incredible people I never
realized
how much value I'd find in growing teams
I didn't know I was going to come back
to that like I did with sports and
seeing the extraordinary group of people
that are now at Maui Nui and being the
Shield that like ensures there's only
ever great people there ourselves
included in that process
man that is open off and Mission enough
like if I can do those two things really
well that'll be more than enough and
I think that'll go a long way in serving
community and hopefully my kids and yeah
yeah
dig it so last question
is
the billboard question this is sometimes
a dead end so I'll take the blame oh if
it goes sideways but if if it goes well
I'll give you all the credit so
simple question
there is a billboard metaphorically
speaking right you can get a message out
too
hundreds of millions billions of people
could be an image could be a quote could
be a word could be a question could be
anything could also be something you
want to remind yourself of it could be
any of those things what might you put
on that billboard
I remember thinking about this listen to
your podcast for years and it may not
make perfect sense like when you read it
but the first business book I ever read
was called the Little Red Book of
selling it was this like tiny little
thing another book and a quote in there
stuck with me for years and it was pick
up the phone and early in my career that
meant pick up the phone take any
opportunity do everything like just
always always pick up the phone and
later as I've grown
it's turned into less of like pick up
the phone and take those opportunities
but address the thing that is in front
of you that you don't want to like have
the uncomfortable conversation like pick
up the phone like just do it and what
it's resulted in is
a very rapid iteration of like taking
action constantly and not
not being a lot of downtime in between
it and now it means today like just
addressing all of those hard things that
are like in front of growth or with my
family so if that billboard said pick up
the phone
that could mean something to somebody
really different like maybe that's your
mom that's calling that you don't want
to like pick up the phone but for me it
just it has constantly iterated and it's
been this crazy thing that has stuck
with me for I mean I read that book like
20 years ago and it's just this thing
that plays in my head all the time like
when I see something that I don't want
to do or I know that has to get done
immediately I say pick up the phone and
I just like
I'm able to just do it immediately yeah
pick up the phone
get a reminder what a good reminder
Jake Muse
Francia
so nice to see you man oh always so good
to see you my friend people can check
out Maui Nui at Maui Nui venison.com on
all the socials at Maui Nui venison
I love this company I love the ethos I
love your family
I love the impact that it's having
and this is not because we're meeting
today but if if you look at my backpack
right now I have three of the what's the
right way to describe them pepper sticks
yep is that fair enough so the peppers
ticks which are
I guess now I know what 10 to 11 grams
of protein per stick something like that
so if I need to be on the run and I need
some quick pick me up for breakfast or
snack or quick lunch just 30 grams ish
of protein I just throw three of those
in and a lot of my protein for the last
several years
has been Maui Nui and I feel good about
it I feel really good about it and I
feel good overall so what an adventure
yeah well I can't tell you how much
we've appreciated the support and
insight and advice so it's been highly
impactful as well
yeah what uh what a gift it's been to
get to know you and to realize like you
said well I mean your family is very
Down to Earth but connected with the
Earth
in a in a way that is very aspirational
for me and so I I really think very
fondly I still have photos on my phone
of just us sitting around a fire you
know and whether it's it's having a fire
at night and just decompressing or
having the most delicious slash shitty
instant coffee in the morning which is
just fantastic though
it really makes a difference when you
get up at five in the morning and it's
just [__] you know you've been
freezing your nuts off which surprise
surprise can happen in Hawaii at
elevation you have that coffee and
you're with people you really care about
you feel close too it's it puts in Stark
relief how much nonsense and garbage
we fill our lives with when
in fact when you just sit with close
Bonds in close proximity and connection
to Nature
how much something very deep is
nourished that alleviates much of the
hunger for a lot of these trappings a
true connection to place whether
personally or professionally can
essentially solve for anything
connection to place Jake Muse so great
to see you man oh thank you for being
here thank you so much my friend and to
everybody listening we will link to all
sorts of stuff all the books HHS video
clips everything you can imagine that
we've covered in this conversation
probably not the secret Pinterest board
you have to make that for yourself we'll
put those in the show notes at Tim
docblog podcasts you can just search
Jake and it will pop right up and
as always my recommendation is be just a
little bit Kinder than is necessary not
only to others but to yourself
and until next time thanks for tuning in
Mahalo Nui